attendre détester la merde que la vie jette sur mon
chemin
détester attendre de m'échapper mrs.
Vinson a 53 ans une fois qu'il était un
sculpteur prometteur avec des expositions de
Paris New York et le documentaire de
Castle
Vincent travaille en permanence sur
quelque chose de mystérieux dans la cave de
la maison une installation artistique que
personne n'a jamais vue appelée le secret
de la vie Vincent est  une affaire lourde n'a jamais
eu une telle liberté que chez les fous et les
fous les fous sont vraiment eux
-mêmes c'est pourquoi ils les enferment je les ai
connus jeunes et vieux ceux qui parlent et
ceux qui se taisent même un qui est
tout fou mais pas si bête  après tout
j'ai vu des fumeurs faire
les cent pas parler mesurer 100 pas passer et
revenir tourner en rond ou pas en
rond après tout la
survie est extrêmement difficile un
poète mort n'écrit pas d'où l'
importance de rester en vie je veux
aller à la plage je ne  ça m'est égal
[Musique]
mais c'est tout
toi